[Music]
[Music]
that's what i know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right glad to be with you this very
special live stream producing the in
video studio as always is
jared who is not gay follow him and oh
we need to shut that tv monitor off
i'm here oh you know what i'm hearing
myself
on my computer recently in video studio
as always if this is not a real show
it's not real is jared who is not gay
follow him on twitter at not gay gear
and me at s credit fulfill my league
obligations draw your own conclusions
and gerald morgan at g morgan jr that's
right baby this is your first time in
the studio that's right yeah i feel this
is not my first time in the studio but
you know right in the studio right
um well listen we have tonight debate
bernie sanders vs ted cruz i'm looking
forward to very much
because i have not
seen this yet we talked about this would
be the actual the purest form of debate
we never got to see it in the primaries
we never got to see it in a general
election i always said i want to see ted
cruz versus bernie sanders it's only
health care debate but we have uh to go
along tonight you thought we'd be done
with the live streaming
after presidential debates there's more
there's more but wait there's more
aids that's not on the table tonight to
talk about but that's always lurking
behind the curtain i feel like you
should be upfront about that so
is that program doing that or is that
just our tv monitor keeps going blind i
think uh you told me it was fixed you're
fired
so um
beverages of choice tonight we have a
drinking game yes bring up the drinking
game not gerry for people who don't know
the rules okay you have to take a drink
every time bernie sanders uses the word
free
access don't don't pour that yet that's
the hero shot affordable you need to
read this wall street you need to read
this correctly if he says fair share
you're not reading this correctly you
have to read as i can't my voice is shot
people saw the facebook live stream they
can hear me right now i sound like
lindsay lohan after an all-night bender
with a lesbian dj you have to drink if
ted cruz ever smiles uncomfortably right
away alcohol poisoning starts a sentence
or rebuttal with
well
says the words radical islamic terrorism
or freedom or if he tells a personal
story so uh everybody beverages up
i sure hope you're using the
vessel of choice that's all choice
the only one
that will do
switch cameras here look at this look at
this look at that that is a
a perfect head oh hey before we go to it
they're going to be streaming really
quickly we have our own uh special guest
tonight we haven't had him on the show
in a while there you go cheers cheers by
the end of tonight i will hate you
i will despise you that's actually
pretty good a little coffee beer not bad
uh a special guest john gutenberg we
haven't had him on uh in a while he his
journey for bernie went viral he's a
documentarian from canada uh jean-guy
will be checking in with you are you
there sir
are you there jean-gee are you there
is jongi there i don't think we're there
he's got he's got some funny wi-fi
connection out there jeanie's not there
let's see
there you know my journey for barney is
not finished at uh election you know uh
we can't forget the issue that matters
so i'm ready to go and ready to watch uh
that guy wash uh uses uh like uh like a
broom on the floor with uh that guy ted
cruz you know i don't know what that
means i don't think hey junkie i
appreciate i'm glad you came out but i
don't i don't know what i don't think
i don't know what you mean use a broom
on the floor you know that's not my
first language uh uh mop i think that's
uh for that one uh
you know you don't have to tell me to
time
is going to be there anyway you know oh
so he'll be taking part in the drinking
game i assume oh look there he is
already he's just going for it all right
uh we need to bring up the stream jared
gerald do you report of this yeah scared
i'm excited i appreciate you bringing me
back when you can have beer on this you
don't seem very grateful for that i
throw a bottle cap at you oh i could
have caught that if you're a good
quarterback but tom brady you are not no
i'm not i'm more like the falcons
um
let's bring this up okay there they are
they're showing them crazy so tweet us
what do you expect to see tonight i
expect to see ted cruz laser in and
bernie sanders promise free stuff
and uh scream out words like socialism
so uh let me see this knocking jared let
me see the decisions behind the podiums
all right now before your opening
statements fear factors like talk about
the ground rules that you both agreed to
you will get 90 seconds to answer
questions posed to you 45 seconds for
responses and rebuttals timing lights
will guide you as we mentioned a handful
of members of our audience which include
both critics and defenders of the
affordable care act will question you in
addition to questions from jake and
myself as moderators we will guide the
debate and we will begin himself two
minute opening statements
let me begin by thanking cnn for
sponsoring this debate and let me thank
all of those who are watching
let me get right to the point
senator cruz like most republicans has
said that he wants to repeal the
affordable care act yes or so-called
obamacare preach let me tell you what
that will mean to the american people
it means that if you are one of 20
million americans who finally has
received health insurance
at gunpoint
when you get sick you ain't going to be
able to go to the doctor and when
they're in
you'll be paying those bills for the
rest of your life or maybe you'll go
bankrupt
what the repeal of the aca means that if
you are one of 10 million senior
citizens who today is struggling with
the outrageous cost of prescription
drugs
your prescription drug costs are going
to be caused on there about i think two
thousand drinking games should be if not
it should be called the repeal of the
aca means is that if you are suffering
with cancer with diabetes
with serious mental illness yeah i think
you know that
be put into a position
where you may be elected
conditioned by the insurance companies
because they might have a baby he's
hitting all the high notes here isn't he
he really is is the aca
nobody believes that it is and nobody
believes that we do not need to improve
it but the debate is whether we kill it
entirely or we make improvements in it
and i will tell you
overwhelming majority of the american
people say do not simply repeal the aca
make improvements last point
the united states is the only major
country on earth not to guarantee health
care to all people as a right oh we
should put it right in there
i drink every time bernie says right the
aca has been a step forward we have got
to go further and join every other major
country on earth and say that if you are
an american every other major country
guarantees you don't have to pay for any
national defense thank you thank you
senator sanders senator cruz what should
happen with health care in america
well dan
come on
thank you thank you guys for hosting
this uh thank you for bernie for for
joining this and and and thank you to
cnn for hosting
we have this that are sound bites that
are 60 seconds or 90 seconds on a topic
and i appreciate cnn devoting real time
to this issue
because it matters
personal in a way that
is different from most other political
issues
health care affects our families it's
our moms
health care is personal it's the future
it
can quite literally be whether we live
edward the sound guy has a bottle of red
wine
and this is an issue
where bernie sanders and i have
fundamentally different approaches
fundamentally should have been bernie
and the democrats should have been on
the list want government
to control health care
i trust you
and i trust your doctors i think health
care works better when you're in charge
of your family's health care decisions
when you can sit down with your doctor
and decide the care that's best for your
family
without government setting rules without
government rationing without wait
periods
and that's the fundamental division
you know six years ago when obamacare
was being adopted it's possible that
reasonable minds could have differed
on whether this was a good idea
but six years into it we've seen the
results
now it's true remember obamacare
a series of promises were made to us by
president obama
number one most infamously
if you like your plan
you can keep your plan
president obama said that 37 different
times
as six million people across this
country discovered that was not true
when they had their plans canceled again
the grassy knoll tonight if you like
your doctor you can keep your doctor
again millions discovered that wasn't
true
and president obama promised the
american people the average family's
premiums would drop twenty five hundred
dollars
not only wasn't that true but the
average family's premiums have risen
five thousand dollars that's why people
are unhappy with this disaster of a law
because it's driven up the cost of
health care it's reduced your choice
it's reduced your freedom but didn't
choice freedom
senator cruz thank you so much uh we
have a lot of questions for both of you
from members of the audience but before
we get to them i want to ask about a
pressing matter on capitol hill and i'll
start with you senator cruz house
speaker paul ryan said today that the
legislation to repeal and replace
obamacare would be done this year on
sunday president trump said that a plan
may not smile uncomfortably in 2000
until 2018 not that it would but then it
may not be rolled out of the judgment
call here is a lot of uncomfortable
smiles that are full and we need
somebody to tweet us
a broken promise
listen i think everyone agrees there is
an urgency to honor the promises we made
you know since obamacare was passed
we've had multiple elections 2010 2014
2016
where the number one issue in each of
those elections was obamacare and you
know what we're arguing here was argued
in front of the american people the
democrats said over and over again
or something all of these people i'm in
for a rough night guys
we're very sorry that was the argument
that was made to the american people did
he skip
he said
twenty feet left sixteen i believe for a
mandate from the voters they said we're
tired of premiums going up
we're tired of deductibles going up
we're tired of losing our doctors of
less choices so yes should congress move
personal story to repeal obamacare
that's borderline
once obamacare's repealed
once obamacare is repealed we need
common sense reform
that increases competition that empowers
patients that gives you more choices
that puts you in charge of your choice
rather than empowering government
bureaucrats we're supposed to be on
there with freedom these have been
common
as i would know so we call them six
years republicans have been proposing
your pro-choice for six years democrats
have been fighting saying no changes at
all to obamacare even as people were
hurting
and losing their coverage this election
is about honoring the promises
senator sanders well the truth is
that the republicans are now in a panic
yes because clearly they're backs
against the wall bernie
repeal i've got them right where i want
them without improvements in it without
a plan to make it better would be an
absolute disaster
so when ted talks about giving people
choice here's your choice choice you got
cancer and you know the doctor and the
insurance company says we're not going
to cover it we can't make money on you
because you have cancer you have a
pre-existing condition
yes
and here's another choice insurance
companies
with cancer if you have diabetes
and you're spending a whole lot on
health insurance
the insurance companies will say sorry
we're only going to spend x dollars
because we got to make money off you
that's the function of private insurance
so do we
to take risks to take calculated risks
yeah so can you believe it if you go in
and you're eating fried snickers and
oreos
the insurance company won't cover you
yes bernie just like they shouldn't
cover you because you're mentally insane
i wouldn't cover your prozac much higher
before we had the affordable care act
senator
you know it is interesting to hear so
much of the democratic uh rhetoric that
by zhang is still controlling
are you still there you're saying the
insurance companies are two go for it
now this is an example of what john is
drinking famously said facts or stubborn
things let's talk about some facts
in 2008
the 10 largest insurance companies
america made just over 8 billion dollars
profit
in 2016 2015 rather
those same 10 largest companies made 15
billion dollars in profit insurance
company profits have doubled under
obamacare that was the result bernie
helped write obamacare i don't think the
federal government ought to be passing a
law that doubles
the business of insurance companies but
obamacare basically forced people to buy
private insurance yes they couldn't have
pre-existing conditions but there were
no caps on premiums or deductibles so it
really was a way for them to sort of
wheeze women act like they were working
on behalf of the little guy as they've
always claimed and the little guy voted
for donald trump in response while
providing a big kick back to insurance
companies who by and large
favored democrats that elections are
higher and you know who's making out
like gangbusters
the insurance companies and those in
government whose solution is let's have
an expression
this thing isn't working
i find myself in agreement
the function of insurance companies is
not to provide quality health care to
all people to make as much money as they
possibly can ted
let's work together on a medicare for
all single-payer program
so we're finally going to get see
in his circles when he shows up to black
lives matter in college bong circles
this kind of you know argument is
considered we are the only major country
on earth that allows private insurance
companies to run the system
but it's not only the points that ted
made about the insurance company
the country that invents the even the
largest portion of drugs that come to
market it's not even close we cured
things like outrageous things
compensation
ted let's work together we're going to
get those insurance companies out of
health care we'll move to a medicare for
all health care programs
well actually what i still will say
bernie is i would love for us to work
together going after big pharma and in
particular taking on the fda right now
it takes two billion dollars to approve
a new drug now i've introduced
legislation to reform the fda process so
that new health care so that we can be
curing diseases and we can check in with
john g
are you there sir are you watching thus
far hey man i'm doing okay you know my
my boy is uh
he's doing good you know and uh i don't
know about that uh that's uh that's uh
a real party
okay
which is the greediest of many reading
corporate interests in washington and
i'll tell you what i'm going to
introduce legislation to have medicare
negotiate prices
legislation and stop i am going through
this again legislation to allow
americans to buy less expensive medicine
in canada the uk and other countries
let's take on the greed of pharma
substantially lower prescriptions
let me make a response to this because
this is a good discussion the whole
point of having an extended discussion
is say as you know
with drug reimportation bringing in
drugs from canada and other countries
just a couple of weeks ago on the senate
floor i voted with you you voted for me
in support of that in support of
reimportation
it was the right thing to do but i'll
tell you a much bigger barrier than that
is the fact that you know in the last 20
years
the fda has approved only three child
cancer drugs
in 20 years
because the burdens are so great i
introduced legislation that said if a
drug is approved in another major
country if it's approved in europe or
japan or our major respected partners
that the fda has got 30 days to approve
it here we shouldn't be telling people
with life-threatening diseases you can't
do everything you can to save your lives
that would be a great thing we'd make
news if you and i joined
but that is not the major problem the
major problem with the pharmaceutical
industry is you know what
they could double or triple the prices
you paid
have you been here this whole time so
good to see you
uh we do want to talk more about that
later but i want to get to some uh some
of the questions from our audience one
of the most popular parts of obamacare
is require as you mentioned earlier
requiring insurance companies to cover
people with pre-existing conditions if
obamacare is repealed 52 million
americans could lose that guaranteed
coverage because of their medical
histories one of them is niosha ponder
who is fighting breast cancer and
currently undergoing radiation ethnicity
senator cruz if obamacare is repeating
all right is there anything
sure the provisions are in place so that
half of my paycheck won't be spent on
health care i didn't ask for cancer
i never smoked i never drank a lot i've
lived a pretty healthy lifestyle
i fear that
i feel that if if i don't have obamacare
if i'm not covered
then my pre-existing condition of breast
cancer and remaining treatments will
make it difficult for me to afford
insurance senator cruz what can you do
to protect people like me
who are alive because of what's your
shirt today
well neil thank you for asking that
question well you just said well at home
diagnosed on april 25th 2016. oh wow
well you where you're you're doing great
you know where our prayers are with your
siblings
and and my mom was diagnosed
with elections
and she went through two years
later
thank god she is a survivor
and and i will tell you our medical
innovation has been incredible dealing
with breast cancer so all of us
our prayers and thoughts are with you
thank you uh you know you asked about
people who get sick and not wanting your
insurance canceled not wanting your
premiums to go up that's absolutely
right that is absolutely right and and
if you look at every proposal that's
been submitted every every significant
proposal that's been submitted to
replace obamacare to fix the problems in
the health care system after obamacare
has gotten rid of all of them protect
people in your situations all of them i
look at this insurance companies from
the counselling because they get opened
up they prohibit insurance companies
up the insurance rates
it's even enhanced by the mud club it
enhances everything this one does i
think it's for alcoholics who want to
drink beer faster i think that's the
invention there just hook into my veins
yeah pretty much senator sanders
responded i cannot believe what you just
said
it's a direct contradiction everything
you ran for president on
what ted has said is he wants to get rid
of all federal mandates did you say that
a hundred times i didn't say it once
i will
[Laughter]
[Music]
get rid of that every word of obamacare
excuse me the only way
we are going to make it
he was in the green room with a voodoo
doll with pins
i don't even know how i got here i came
here playing pokemon go
i chose tonight i chose i chose tonight
i should have known better yeah to do
so when you hear
uh ted and other republicans like we're
going to get rid of all of obamacare
we're going to leave it to the states
well what do you think the states are
good do you think they're going to
maintain
the uh ability to to protect people with
pre-existing conditions you mean the
risk pool that texas had to take care of
everybody like her in that situation
that's why that's what we would have
done it would have been perfect actually
if you do that could you just clarify
will you support anything that doesn't
mandate people with pre-existing
conditions continue to have coverage
look my response as i said hundreds of
times on the campaign trail yes we
should repeal every word of obamacare
but if you listen to the next sentence i
always said we're not done yet with
health health care reform when we do
that we need health care reform in the
principles of health care reform
they should expand competition
they should power
tonight is it longer government from
getting between you and your doctor i
talked about all sorts of common sense
ideas to do just that and and as i said
a proposal that is consistent in
virtually every one of the pieces of
republican legislation that's been filed
is a prohibition on insurance companies
canceling people because they got sick
and you know bernie it's it's easy to
say to people gosh you're going to lose
your coverage what do the democrats say
to the six million people who had their
health insurance canceled
wait wait wait well
thank you like every cartoon who sees a
really attractive other girl cartoon
tomorrow you wake up and you go to the
doctor and you discover that you have
cancer
all right
you just discovered it and the insurance
companies say hey you're not a good deal
for us we can't make money off of you
you will not get
that health insurance
so i think when people like ted talk
about
repealing obamacare repealing government
mandates this is a government mandate
and it is a damn good mandate and a
humane mandate and senator cruz if you
would out answer now some more
constitutionality of a mandate so
you are saying that she will continue to
have health care she and others who have
pre-existing conditions there and you're
going to make sure that that is a
mandate and a requirement in whatever
legislation what i've said is virtually
all of the republican legislation that
has been filed that the democrats have
opposed
edward maintains a continuity of
coverage so that insurance companies
can't cancel policies and you know the
question i asked a minute ago that
bernie chose not to answer
is what do the democrats say to the six
million people who had their insurance
policies canceled who got a notification
in the mail that that you don't get to
see your doctors anymore and not just
the people who were canceled
there are people all over this country
who can't afford health insurance
because of obamacare who the deductibles
are so high the premiums are so high
they say you know what my family we
can't make it on this personal story and
you know you talk about the people
covered by obamacare here's something
most people don't smile uncomfortably
most of the people covered by obamacare
are on medicaid
they jammed a bunch more people in
medicaid tell you what happens people
are outside you didn't drink anything
you drink twice
worse
health outcomes senators and people with
private insurance i'd like to see a lot
more people on private wait you're
speaking truth let's go
cut to bernie rather than but but it's
relevant to he's saying people are going
to lose their health care if you want
health care we want as many people as
possible to be able to afford insurance
policies that protect you when
to take from a less oppressed class to
give to an oppressed class which is
typically a minority yes that's what it
is he doesn't consider the fact that
what about everyone else who has to pay
two three times the price for their
premiums they don't matter because
they're moderately successful
that is what had said but he also said
if you have an illness it has to be kept
but really we are moving into an era
where millions of people who develop
terrible illnesses
will not be able to get insurance and
god only knows how many of them will die
so senator sanders um you just heard
senator bring up an issue donald trump
said he was going to keep the
pre-existing clause which is silly and
it doesn't work but he did say that so
it's kind of removed so that their
insurance is unaffordable one of them is
our in our audience right now her name
is melissa borkowski she's a nurse
practitioner from florida she's a mother
of four she and her husband are paying
more than a thousand dollars a month to
insure their family for a plan with a 13
000
deductible melissa give us the spiel
about healthy lifestyle good evening
senators thank you for your time
as you said i'm a nurse practitioner
i've worked in healthcare for over 25
years now but under obamacare i'm not
able to get the health services i need
for myself or my family
last year i had a very abnormal pap
smear and needed additional
can we add that 13 000.
either way
i wasn't able to afford to get those
tests done so now i sit here wondering
if i have an undiagnosed cancer
and that will eventually take me away
from my four children
am i unusual 25 000
years old it covers a little more
preventative services
senator sanders
my question is about your smear
so much money for an insurance plan i
understand absolutely useless that not
all smears of pep are equal
you asked a great question and the
answer is it is totally absurd it is
totally absurd
it should be free
we should be next thing
in my senate chambers
the real question which is never talked
about or very rarely talked about what
is it is why we end up spending as a
nation
twice as much per capita on health care
as do the people of any other country
in canada you know what you would get
the health care that you need no you
would just if you were in the uk france
germany scandinavia you would get the
health care union you would get worse
but then
the idea that we have policies like that
like the one you described is clearly an
outrage and should tell every american
that we've got to join the rest your
plan did it realize your plan guarantees
made it happen
and it's an
outrageous by the way your 13 000
deductible which didn't exist prior to
obamacare for most people thank you very
much
senator cruz
you know melissa i'm sorry for the
challenges you're facing there are many
people in america struggling with
exactly what you are in the wreckage of
obamacare with skyrocketing premiums
with deductibles that are unaffordable
and with really limited care and and i
will commend bernie for his candor i
mean his view all along was that we need
government-run and government-controlled
health care for everyone and indeed as
he said here tonight he thinks other
countries do it a lot better than
america he often points to canada the
united kingdom he says why do we pay
more well there's a reason we pay more
than those countries we get a lot more
and a lot better health care let me give
you some basic facts as i noticed in all
the democratic parties they spend less
and have better care of the facts on the
other side which is not true the united
states population controlled delivers
three times as many mammograms as europe
two and a half times the number of mri
scans
more c-sections we provide more health
care not only zero through planned
parenthood in the united kingdom for
example wait times in 2013 you waited 72
days for cataract surgery you waited 89
days for hip replacement
95 days for knee replacement
there are 3.7 million people in the
united kingdom right now on a waiting
little go through his notes like i don't
have notes on this
whenever you put government in charge of
health care what it means is they ration
they decide you get care and you don't
i don't think the government has any
business
he may seem stiff he may seem staccato
but he just brought a litany of facts
and statistics and then bernie will say
i don't think they have the right to
deny you it's a human right
deductibles empower you and put you back
in charge of your healthcare senator
cruz thank you senator sanders let me
ask you just as as part of melissa's
questions
through obamacare through the insurance
exchange there was a nearly 25 percent
decline
[Laughter]
there are five states that only have one
insurer providing insurance on the
exchange
drakey was predictable you said it was a
rule that's true ted talks about the
problems that exist
in other countries in terms of waiting
lines it talks about rationing
let's see if he says what i said we have
enormous rationing in this country wait
really when you have 28 million people
who have no health insurance that's
rationing when you have people who can't
afford to go to the doctor you can't
afford to buy prescriptions
affordable
twice can't afford the prescription
drugs that's prescribed that's called
rationing except there's no rules free
drinks everyone three drinks more on
that it's just people don't have money
to buy what they need
in terms of health care to answer your
question jake what i have long supported
within the context of obamacare as we
move toward a medicare for all
single-payer program
is a public option there should be a
medicare type public option available
in all exchanges in all states in this
country and i think that would
substantially lower the cost
of health care in this country and
provide real competition
these premiums and he's saying i believe
if we do this i think it might
he's dealing with phantom fears and
phantom theories
that is socialism versus free enterprise
i love this debate well and we're
talking about health insurance not
health care let's make sure we
understand that good point gerald two
health insurance plans that's it oh
it's really quite striking
that the communities that have been
hammered by this disaster of a law said
enough already
now
bernie likes talking about a public
option that's another way of saying
government control of your health care
it's socialized medicine and what does
it mean every country where it's been
applied
you've seen rationing you've seen
government deciding especially seniors
seniors you don't get the health care
you need now bernie mentions canada
quite a bit i know quite a bit about
canadian health care i was born there
you know bernie that maybe the best
argument against your position is you
know
ted cruz and bernie sanders and say
i want to look like the guy on the left
there is a picture of health here in the
united states he's softening himself up
a little bit to the audience i'm
reminded of a comment ronald reagan used
to say he had a mini stroke about east
berlin about the berlin wall
he said the funny thing
the leftists never seem to notice the
machine guns all point one direction
was fleeing communism and coming to
freedom if you look at socialized
medicine people leave their tens and
hundreds of thousands every year leave
socialized medicine countries because
they want to get a hip replacement a
knee replacement you know the governor
of one of the canadian provinces
came to america to get heart surgery and
he was a governor in canada and by the
way in your home state of vermont your
hospitals advertised with canadian flags
come to american hospitals you'll get
better health care
i don't want to mess up our health care
i want patients all of us to be in
charge of our health care not government
deciding what happens sanders can't
close his mouth look at that he looks
like he's trying to like government just
don't have time to pass a kidney stone
later
[Music]
the
their health care systems in which by
the way poll after poll shows not that
they don't have problems of course they
have problems every health care system
in the world has problems but i am not
seeing those countries junking their
universal health care system which
provide health care to all of their
people at one half the cost per capita
i don't see conservative prime ministers
doing that to go to the american health
care system our system is wasteful it is
dysfunctional it is incredibly
bureaucratic you talk about this health
insurance because he's so wrong
the people may not be complaining
because of giving free things but the
governments are being forced to move
toward a more privatized plan as canada
did in the supreme court okay versus
we've talked about it they're moving our
way while bernie wants us to move their
way they've already run out of money
they're done and bernie never talks
about the number of of mris the number
of mammograms if we cut you know you
look at the elders in much
the elderly here
when when there are 11 000 people
watching us right now what are you doing
on tuesday nights
what are you doing what are you doing
that's great let's just install
our entire oh there's seven thousand now
weird
come back those watching tweet me what
are you drinking this evening
we had a four corners local bus matter
so let's so let's talk about for example
wait you're supposed to stream from the
united kingdom in glasgow bernie's
matching a move
it turned away three women who were in
labor
because they couldn't take care of them
in worcester england a man was left on
an ambulance gurney for five hours
and he waited seven hours
before he received a stan in angioplasty
someone on a hospital in essex
is bernie part of the garage life-saving
potential life-saving surgery
for a patient with esophageal cancer
because there were no free beds in the
intensive care unit one more example in
wales
an 82 year old woman who had who had
fallen
waited eight hours on the floor before
an ambulance arrived
her daughter sat beside her in the
ordeal described it as one of the
longest nights of our life this is what
happened when government takes over
health care every example on earth
the result is rationing and waiting
periods and you the citizens being told
no you can't whiskey nicole christie
says juice
aaron
saltfist says drinking elysium
split shop
no
right here in the united states we
should be proud of that but if you are
working class
you're going to be
having a very difficult time affording
the outreach
every single year
tens of thousands of our fellow
americans die
[Music]
come into their offices
he's doing good very sick you know
and the excitement i feel like
strong [ __ ] up i feel fresh
okay we'll check back with you
the only honest man
on the side of bernie let's go back to
work
we just heard that story a moment ago
and some of those people die
and others end up in the hospital at
outrageous costs
for illnesses that have could could have
been treated
initially at far less cost so please
don't tell me about rationing this
country has more right you made no point
you made no points about it the
rationing is done
by
income and working-class people and poor
people today are suffering as a result
of that we're going to take a very quick
break the debate will continue right
after this with senators ted cruz and
bernie sanders stay with us okay so uh
let's do a score card here
can we can we we can turn on the air for
a bit right how much is that going to
mess up the sound
let's let's turn on the air here it's
not too hard
if you hear a little bit of buzzing i
like sweating or jared pissing himself
he's a very low tolerance um
hey sound guy edward make sure that the
temperature is below the room
temperature did you okay
he never knows what he'll do right he'll
turn on the end
at 75 in the room and he sets it to 78.
thank you for all of your tweets uh we
have a scorecard uh genuinely if you're
looking at this as an objective observer
who's who's getting the better of this
ted cruz but again you're you're making
emotional arguments to people who
respond very well to emotional arguments
i think the people who like bernie are
still going to like bernie because they
don't they don't care about the facts or
statistics i mean they supported his
economic plan
they
very casual relationship with stats and
statistics okay they they don't really
want good health care they just want an
insurance plan that says i can go and
live my life eat what i want never
exercise make really bad decisions and
one day poof i'm in bad shape and i need
your help how about the people that do
take care of themselves and spend time
effort and money getting checkups and
doing all kinds of stuff by the way tons
of that stuff is free it doesn't cost
you a thing by the way also those people
are the ones much more likely to see as
far as a comparative increase in their
premiums because the people who were
healthy people who
take care of themselves this guy yeah
right here
you're right there with leticia
myself very healthy
i do not eat whiskey cake gerald wait no
that's not true it is we split it now
you split in the loosest sense of the
word i look down like how did that
happen so i i think that is important
people need to realize the people who do
take care of themselves the people who
you actually want
insurance companies betting on they're
the ones more likely to have to pay more
and dropping out yes you know the person
who's most likely to drop out of
insurance right now hey it's really hard
now because the government's going to
penalize you at gunpoint but the person
most likely to drop out is that college
student who's an athlete who's super fit
who's super healthy who did all these
things to try and bring their insurance
premiums down
and instead saw them go up and that's
the exact kind of person you need in the
healthcare insurance risk pool to
mitigate it for the person with the
smear of pap
oh man you want me in your insurance
pool you really do i'm the i'm the
ringer
thank you yes
yes i'm paying for you to have these
surgeries and pap smears that go awry
apparently and and now you want me to
pay more i'm okay paying a little bit
more right i'm okay helping make sure
there's a backstop but that's not what
he's talking about we had that already
we had the backstop in texas for sure
right the big risk pool if you had a
pre-existing condition you went there
you know how i know that i went there i
had back surgery and it was not the end
of the world my premium went up like 50
bucks on top of that yeah had 115
thousand dollar back surgery ended up
having
zero back surgery well i had to had to
sign a a writer so that my bag was never
covered again so that was that was an
option i ended up finally getting
well they covered it for i believe two
years under that rider and then never
again but after that i'm good now i can
go get insurance with anybody and it
doesn't come up but how do they make
money if you have 115 000 back surgery
well they lost on that one
they got a little screwed what do you
want me to say but the thing is
personally my income was not affected
because i had aflac had a health savings
account that was fully funded geez i i
think i was being a little bit
responsible and i also had short-term
disability insurance
it is possible [ __ ] it thank you thank
you
short term yes
you've only had one beer and that's not
fair no that's not true at all jared's
been cheating jared you haven't even
opened a second i'm working out i've
already been calling you on not drinking
when you're supposed to important report
back
do you think bernie passed the kidney
stone
i think it's in a jar underneath that
podium i want to show you something
was that that was bernie
work on it
let's go back let's bring up some
businesses and with us to discuss that
is laronda hunter who owns i'm jacob
hello
under the controls of obamacare my
business has been restricted from
expansion i'm from fort worth texas i
own five fantastic fantastic sam's here
from secular talk to read after we
employ between 45 and is that the lesser
judge
employees
my original plan was to open
more salons and employ more people
however under obamacare i am restricted
um because i it requires me to uh
furnish in
health insurance if i employ more than
50 people i don't understand economics
unfortunately the profit
my industry is very thin
and i'm not a wealthy person so it's
impossible for me to grow my business
my question to you senator sanders is
how do i grow my business
how do i employ more
raising the prices to my customers or
lowering wages to my employees vultures
in the jungle book lauren de la run
oh you own five
salons that's correct and you employ
close to 50 people just under and what
kind of health insurance do you provide
to them zero i don't i none you probably
know health insurance correct she's
going to vilify her watch let me be let
me give you an answer you will not be
happy with
uh and that is i think uh that for
businesses that employ 50 people or more
given the nature of our dysfunctional
health care system right now
where most people do get their health
insurance through the places that they
work i'm sorry
i think that in america today everybody
should have health care and if you have
more than 50 people you know what i
think i'm afraid to tell you
a piece of [ __ ] you have three houses
one that's only 40 minutes from the
other one up on lake champlain you piece
of [ __ ] you don't even ask her about her
profit margins you even ask her how many
people she employs how many of them are
part-time how many of them have been
forced onto working part-time because of
obamacare because of the current laws
that force small businesses again 50
people is not a lot at all you piece of
[ __ ] and this is so clear right now when
he tries to say we're talking about the
multi-billion dollar corporations we're
talking about the big people this woman
probably barely earns a six-figure
income if that i wouldn't be surprised
if most years she makes less than those
50 employees that she's talking about
you piece of [ __ ] everyone watching this
show right now knows somebody who
probably has a business on that scale of
size when bernie sanders says
forevermore that he's only going after
the top one percent
right here he's going after women like
that he is not a nice guy he is buying
your vote he is a walking talking
bumbling piece of human [ __ ] what's the
drink to that i think actually what
bernie told you is the same thing
president obama said it's the same thing
democrats have said which is that you
the small business
you're apparently a bad actor
because you're not allowed to to
manufacture money
you know let me introduce y'all to two
terms that become really common
29ers and 49ers
29ers
are the millions of people across this
country that have been forced into
part-time work that used to have
full-time
employment and are now working 29 hours
a week because obamacare kicks in at 30
hours a week
and a lot of them are people they're
single moms they're teenagers they're
immigrants they're people who are
struggling and then 49ers there are
millions of small businesses in the
exact situation you're in you know a
couple of months ago i was out in west
texas was visiting a dairy farmer
driving around the dairy farm now listen
to this and you tell me he's popping his
smell you tell me he's looking out for
the elite bernie sanders telling the
small business owner that you have to
pay for everybody else's health
insurance period because i have a
mandate and i have a pen sitting there
from washington d.c or ted cruz right
now who's talking about giving
businesses and employees the freedom of
choice
because obamacare kicks in at 50 and he
said i could hire 20 or 30 more
employees right now
but obamacare would bankrupt my business
and that's millions of small businesses
so we're here at gw let me speak for a
minute to all the young people that was
a personal story by the way when you
come out to college with way too much
student loans
my guess is you'd like to get a job
and millions of small businesses being
told
by the democrats tough luck we don't
care if it drives you out of business
that's taken away opportunity and it's
hurting in particular the most
vulnerable it's one of the most damaging
things about obamacare
senator sanders laronda let me ask you a
question
what happens if one of your employees
becomes ill
what happens
what happens if one of your employees as
happens
in every part of the country
because diabetes gets cancer it's her
fault for sure what do they do with it
they don't have any health insurance
that's what he's saying
you're right i'm sorry i've been
converted because the premiums have gone
up so much this year and because i don't
qualify for any kind of government
subsidies
i don't have for the first time in my
life insurance
um it's just not affordable
unfortunately
she's part of the one percent she can't
even afford insurance and bernie just
vilified her
now he's going to tell her he's going to
appreciate earlier it is absolutely true
that the costs of premiums are going up
no argument
they went up even
higher during the period or george w
bush i'm like
on that's not that's fascinating
verifiably false it's verifiably false
you just pulled the trump
snoke to cover that 29 as well
there are fewer part-time employees
today than they were before that's right
they're out of jobs actually
so thank you for pointing that out the
bottom line is with the situation you
described is honestly absurd
you should not be going around that's a
tip without health insurance your
employees should not be going out around
health insurance we should not be
spending twice as much per person on
health care as though the people have
been anything to absurd for reality
it makes more sense
and fight for a medicare for all
programs are you looking forward by the
way i'm not getting to your age yeah
won't do that
but are you looking forward maybe
get to 65 to get medicare would that be
of help to your family
i expect that that will probably happen
good well i certainly hope it does and i
hope medicare is still there despite the
efforts of senator cruz and others so
that when you at least reach
65 you will be able to get a recent
health insurance program well bernie
since apparently i'm now trying to kill
the elderly um
nice
let me ask you a question
when you heard that her premiums had spy
rock skyrocketed that she can't afford
health insurance
you kind of said well premiums always go
up i mean let me ask you why did
president obama look in the eyes of the
american people and promise laronda that
her health insurance premiums would go
down 2500 a year was he telling the
truth when he said that and where you
and the other democrats telling the
truth when you echoed his promise to the
american people well ted for his thought
is everybody knows health care is pretty
complicated i think president obama is
an honest person i think based on his
assessment that's what he believed what
just happened
it turns out not to be true but i can't
do it on the board no i can't do his
voice so i'm not going to say it now the
bernie no
real question
is why we do spend so much money on
health care and that means that we have
to appreciate that we are spending
hundreds of billions of dollars every
single year not on health care but on
administration and bureaucracy wait what
so much money 100 billion dollars on
administrative bureaucracy really
does he know the numbers that he's
throwing
administrators
their name is bernie
claim so we have to figure out how we
have a simple
system that guarantees health care to
all people when we do that you and your
employees will all have no plans no
facts no strategy whatsoever and no
answer
we do this if we spend this amount of
money buzzwords you'll get this yes
he's the bullet point memo by the way
kyle of secular talk
told ted cruz to shove his prayers up
his ass and sets up he's just such a
[ __ ] that guy he's a [ __ ] and he's a
coward who won't debate anybody comes
from obamacare in fact there's some
amazing stats i'm going to go back and
and get because because they're really
quite powerful
if you
don't do that you work impact he's going
to the stats obamacare's rules alone and
by the way the obamacare rules
are 20 000 pages they're taller than
seven feet to cruise
they generate 51 billion
autumn or something
and more than
172 million hours of paperwork
[Laughter]
200 employees working full time 2 000 a
year
to complete one year of new paperwork
under obamacare that's roughly the
entire population of miami beach florida
doing nothing but filling out obamacare
forms if you want your doctor to get
back to caring for you if you want to
drive down costs get government out of
the business of dictating and
controlling health care well costs
far too much paperwork some of it is a
good point but you know what some of it
is also it is insurance companies
who has filed a claim every answer has
evil companies siemens lurking insurance
companies to make sure that they get
what they are entitled to doc bernie and
his youth was like raped by an insurance
salesman
as to whether or not they can is that a
real possibility
that their patients need huge amounts of
waste that is why we need a simple
system
and as americans have the most
complicated system in the world
i know
very simple
is health care a right of all people
is it or not
ted doesn't think it is i do think it is
and then if we agree and i think most
americans do that it is a right how do
you provide health care to all people
with high quality in a cost
effectiveness
medicaid jared hasn't even opened his
second bottle
it works well right now you get it 65 i
think every american senator sanders i
want to pick you up
i'm a sipper all of you are cheaters
it's not a sipper that's not the
drinking game edward the sound guy is
the only one with a pendulous pair and
all of you are walking around with yours
you were talking about paperwork from
insurance companies i agree there's way
too much paperwork from insurance
companies i'd like insurance companies
to have less power someone said
he said entitlement so
you and i could agree on a common sense
reform of allowing laronda to purchase
health insurance of any of the 50 states
right now she's a texan it's illegal for
her to purchase health insurance
anywhere else that would give her choice
if she doesn't like what the texas texas
companies are offering she can go to
oklahoma she can go to florida she can
go to any other state that creates a
50-state national marketplace it drives
down costs that's what bernie got
[Applause]
my idea is better it'll my deal never
happened
but let's not do yours even though it
would help people out in the short term
or some place they're going to provide
you insurance but you think your
deductibles are high now it will be a
lot higher look ted
and you're right this is a good
discussion all right and here is the
issue ted let me ask you a question sure
is every american entitled
entitled to health care as a right of
being an american yes or no you know i'm
glad you asked that you know right is a
word you use a lot let's talk about what
rights are
rights mean you have a right for
government not to mess with you for
government not to do things if you look
at the bill of rights insurance the bill
of rights free speech means the
government can't silence you when you're
speaking religious liberty means the
government can't control who you worship
what your faith is the second amendment
means the government can't take away
your guns
those are rights you know what the
declaration of independence said
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and that
they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights that
among
life liberty and pursuit of happiness so
what is a right
access to health care what is a right
who's choosing your own doctor you
believe health care is a right
why on earth did you help write
obamacare that caused six million people
to have their health insurance cancelled
that had them lose their doctors and
have people like laronda who can't get
health insurance can't afford
her what you say foreign
her right well two things you're doing
damn
tonight
somebody from bernie's corner needs to
throw this down celebratory toast yes
good job teddy
she has access but you know she's
do you have access right now go out and
get a really great health insurance but
you don't have enough money
enough money
all right that's what he's saying
to what you want to buy one of donald
trump's mansions you have access to do
that as well oh you can't afford five
million dollars for our house sorry
accidents
[Laughter]
that's the poor boy's house get the
health care that they need and they
can't under obamacare second of all
let's some people are probable
oh crap he said something that was true
well i tell you that 20 million more
people did get health insurance all
right we used to have 48 million people
in this country foreign
ted talked to the young people
and he said once you go out with
enthusiasm go out and go to get a job
he's right
but under ted's ideas if obamacare is
repealed right now if you're under 26
you can stay in your parents insurance
program that's one of the things we did
in obamacare good idea ted would repeal
that so as you go out into the real
world
be very careful about not having an
accident you may have to pay for your
own stuff in the real world we're going
to take a quick break we have a lot more
to discuss a lot more
yeah so here
hold on let him finish
oh ted just smiled awkwardly everybody
else better be opening number two all
right fine fine
so i think that was very revealing
uh
bernie sanders was saying you have
access but you don't have enough money
what he's now saying is
access
the ability to the choice of these are
generally what define fundamental rights
the rights to life liberty pursuit of
happiness none of those are guaranteed
outcomes those are all the right to
access the right to choose to pursue
he is now saying you have the right
to enough money by proxy the right to
enough other people's money
to get health care bernie sanders
doesn't believe that decent health care
is a human right he believes that you
have a right to steal from someone else
to purchase health care and he just said
that and i think that's an important
point and i hope other people catch that
from tonight
i think he tries to also paint us into a
bit of a corner obviously you and i want
people to have good health care right
yeah we're making the argument that it's
not possible to give people free health
care so we have to do something else
right right we're trying to come up with
a system that actually will work will
provide innovation we'll keep people
healthy and it's sustainable and will
not bankrupt our country see the rest of
the world yeah and then we get vilified
for saying we don't want people to be
healthy we want poor people to be dying
on the streets from very curable
preventable diseases that's absolutely
not true
i get pissed off a lot about that this
is gerald pissed off by the way not gay
jared
i don't quite gold darn it you guys you
guys i mean golly gee guys you know what
really gets my goat
is when people just they they they they
exercise their authority outside the
realm of constitutionality
yes
oh god what was that that sounded like
hell
it went through the wrong
speaker
trying to do a thud like that was a very
good effect so i do think that was
probably the most revealing segment thus
far yes thank you thank you hopper
hey hopper come on over here oh look at
that
is he coming he's looking up at you like
hey buddy how do i do this i know i
don't like bernie either yes he's
chewing on his toy because bernie
sanders is a prick
my dog even thinks so
so i i do think that was a very
important segment and again if you look
at tonight if you're an objective
observer there's one person with facts
what
[Laughter]
yes
okay and we're done i never said before
that's good stuff a second let me see
kyle kalinski is tweeting right now
uh what's he got oh he blocked me he
must have
i gotta see
people tell me what kyle kalinski is
tweeting the guy who won't the guy who
won't debate the guy who won't show up
the guy who has his balls i'd say balls
in his wife's purse but i think it's in
his husband's purse
let's see i suppose
i don't know spelled let's see
k or c
i don't know
courtney's got a pretty funny gym can we
get gerald on as a guest alex minoofar
that's that's right that's right bring
the page faith frolick says bernie was
yelling at the woman who shared her
personal story exactly it was yelling at
her he was vilifying her then it turns
out she couldn't afford health care
can you please list
tweet the list of things to drink during
the debate i'm falling a little behind
i've had a shiner
cold brew coffee ale
a four corners local buzz honey rye
golden ale
and now i'm on a kolsch
and jared is simply on the first one and
what do you need another one
i'll get you another beer yeah you had a
revolver blood and honey i did yes and
nothing else well
i had two revolver blood and honeys
before i came over so
did you actually i did yes for dinner at
five so i'm you know i'm good i just
taste i need i need something different
someone just sent me a oh
what we're standing by oh they just put
that in there because online they can't
fill the commercial space uh candace
says ted is on fire someone says liberty
for sweden says as a swedish citizen i
cringe when socialists like bernie use
us as an example of success it's a
failure ted you smart you loyal so
apparently black people in sweden let's
go back to the
debate
it's 140 characters come on
senators thanks so much
for participating here i want to ask you
since obama how clear
business owners who have five businesses
and 45 employees when will we stop
oppressing them
the business owners right
what an ass to 11 million low-income
people one of the americans who
benefited benefited from the obamacare
medicaid expansion is carol hardaway of
salisbury maryland carol
thank you they make great i have
multiple sclerosis but could not afford
insurance
without the treatment or medications i
need
i might find these people with walking
they just find like the rolodex from
saint jude's 30 years ago
and just saying all right they're
probably sick enough now
because they refused to expand medicaid
to maryland and within two weeks i
started receiving treatments
through medicaid and am now well enough
to work as a substitute teacher
senator cruz can you promise me that you
and the republican leaders in congress
will have actually have a replacement
plan in place for people like me who
depend on their medicaid
in other words i like my coverage can i
keep it oh jeez
well sure carol thank you for sharing
your story and and
congratulations on dealing with mms it's
it's a terrible disease and
congratulations on on your struggles
dealing with it
you know if you congratulations
more than half of the people who've been
covered under obamacare have been under
medicaid
and the problem is medicaid is is is a
profoundly troubled program and so it it
may be what we're working well with you
but i'll tell you nationally the health
outcomes under medicaid
are really poor nationally 54 percent of
doctors
won't take new medicaid patients
nationally
dental care appointments for moms are
denied at a 63 percent rate on medicaid
the denial rate for private insurance is
4 percent
and medicaid patients
are
almost twice as likely to die from
medical treatment as those with with
private health insurance
the solution for people who are hurting
i believe
we should have a system that allows as
many people as possible
to be on the private health insurance of
your choice
rather than medicaid because the
medicaid outcomes are not working and
people are suffering and what's happened
also
bernie sanders points out free and ted
cruz points out quality that is a
fundamental difference in world view in
your approach to public services
have found their wait times increasing
in fact in illinois on medicaid's over
700 people have died
on the waiting list for care for
medicaid
so i'm glad that you're receiving health
care i can tell you a great many of the
people on medicaid aren't and i'd much
rather see a system
where we can have millions of those on
medicaid getting health insurance and
the only way they can is if we have
competition so that rates are lower so
that you can afford to have health
insurance senator sanders
we heard from a woman who runs
a hair salon
in fort worth who can't afford to
provide health insurance to her workers
and for herself and i promptly
go to another state because that state
is providing medicaid
my friends you are living i know you
don't know this by these stories you're
living in the wealthiest country in the
history of the world
where the rich are becoming phenomenally
richer and buying third homes 43 million
people living in poverty and the middle
class is in decline and these stories
are obscene they should not be taking
place in the united states
now are there problems with
of course carol from secular talks
meltdown right now to those republican
governors around the country this is
good who told poor people
that they would not be able to for the
first time in their lives in many
instances get access to health care
actually to be able to go to it damn it
when the current government paid for the
first he's drinking wine i hope
i hope that those governors sleep well
out of a high quality mug because i
don't know how many people lost their
lives
so once again what we are looking at
this country finally is gonna have to do
in my view with every other major
country does
and yes i believe ted healthcare is
major countries like iceland one
population of 400 dollars this country
has got to join every other major
country and say you can stay home and
get quality care because you're an
american you can run your small business
well and get care because you are an
american that is where we have got to go
well you know when when bernie says well
medicaid has problems
you want to talk about people who lost
their rights
[Music]
put on a waiting list for medicaid after
illinois expanded its message stepped
out on his home state and they died
awaiting care under medicaid why because
medicaid
is ration care those wait lists you know
bernie likes to talk about medicare for
all but let me be clear what his program
is it's medicaid for all
it is rationed care nationally you want
to know what that looks like he keeps
pointing no
to other countries let's look at for
example
the united kingdom
the united kingdom two thousand one
report
noted that thirty nine percent of women
over eighty in the united kingdom
received surgery for breast cancer
compared to 90 percent of the women
under 50.
and that interesting women under or peop
men and women under the age of 55 were
two and a half times more likely than
those over 75 degrees see bernie's
turning like oh
looks like it looks like medicaid it
looks like the people who are suffering
objectively you've got to give this one
the ted it's not even close 291 million
people roughly that are covered by
insurance i don't think we should be
screwing up the insurance of millions of
americans and putting them on the
boosters
numbers any number and that's what
obamacare has moved us down
medicaid has problems and vermont has
problems all over the country it has
problems you know what that solution is
massive cuts
in
federal funding for medicaid
so you got a problem and what ted wants
to do is make it worse you mentioned
dental care and maybe you want so note
to all people who say that bernie
sanders is not a social justice warrior
what he just did was immediately
attribute motive because he was losing
so if you still think that you're an
anti-regressive anti-social justice
warrior but you support bernie sanders
you're an idiot make you have a nice
smile
but they may have to provide real dental
care to the children and others who
absolutely need it furthermore what we
have to do
is we need tens of thousands more
doctors in this country but we're going
to pay you a major crisis
there are areas in urban america and in
rural america where people literally
can't find a doctor to serve their needs
and one of the reasons a number of
reasons for that one of them is you go
to medical school you can come out
hundreds of thousands of dollars in that
here we go free school it's coming up
plastic
tells me that we got to expand the
program called the national health
service corps so that our young people
can get their debts repaid
if they commit to serving in underserved
areas let's get doctors out into the
areas where we need them let me just
jump in if i if i can carol just shake
your head do you what a price
former senator did he answer your
question
questions
the question was senator cruz can you
promise me that you and the republican
leaders in congress will actually have a
replacement plan in place for people
like me who depend on their medicaid she
got medicaid through the obamacare
expansion of medicaid we've all heard
you criticize medicaid what happens to
carol
well what i said jake is that medicaid
isn't working for millions of people and
obamacare made medicaid worse by
expanding the wait list by jamming more
people on it you want to talk about
replacement there's widespread agreement
on replacement plans number one allowing
people to purchase across state lines
giving you more choice now bernie
sanders
you're the party of no there are plenty
of solutions offered by republicans and
conservatives savings account so you can
save in a tax advantage way to meet your
own health care needs
number three making health insurance
portable
so that it goes with you from job to job
i imagine ma'am at some point you you
had insurance with a job
if insurance was portable right now
federal tax law
incentivizes most of us get our
insurance from the government
and if you lose your not from the
government from our employer rather and
if you lose your job you lose that
insurance
one of the best solutions to the problem
of pre-existing conditions is making
health insurance portable that so it
goes with you you know when you lose
your job you don't lose your car
insurance your life insurance your house
insurance there's no reason to lose your
health insurance and if your insurance
is portable it goes with you it's
affordable you have choices
now notice bernie's solutions more we
want more doctors we all agree on more
doctors he said well the government
needs to hire more you know i can point
to something that works on that in texas
we passed tort reform we fundamentally
limited lawsuits and lawsuit abuse and
you know what we've seen we've seen the
number of doctors increasing
dramatically we've seen medical
malpractice premiums
i personally prefer no those are the
kind of things ambulance chases like
john edwards can create sex tapes with
pregnant women while the wife has kids
encouraging people from going to medical
school and training people who are
supposed to be busy performing
and by the way may i say proudly
that vermont is number two
in terms of the percentage of people who
are insured we have relatively few more
uninsured and by the way amazing
millionaires like 400 people when
they're all white and rich
it is massachusetts with romneycare
which was the prototype for the
affordable care act
well you know the nice thing bernie
again
people vote with their feet
and for north of a decade now roughly a
thousand people a day have been moving
to texas
because we have an environment that
allows people to get jobs and so people
vote with their feet and you're right
they're states vermont is a lovely state
it doesn't have a ton of diversity
nearly the populations texas has that
are that are populations that are just
starting when my dad went to texas in
1957 i know a black guy whose street
name is
[Music]
he came to get opportunity that job
enabled him to get another job where he
could get health care that's a much
better solution create an environment
where you don't tax the living daylights
out of people it's wise
to see where they get are we all happy
that under obama we created 15 million
new jobs in the private sector senators
i want to get to some more audience
questions and this one is uh about
that's that's a it's a slight hand trick
all insurance plans you always create a
certain amount of new jobs in the
private sector it's the percentage of
new jobs created in the private sector
versus the public sector which there was
an unbelievable discrepancy with obama
and nearly all previous president
presidents were nearly all the new jobs
created
government
i'm a nursing student at the medical
university of south carolina and i'm
concerned about um crackers
the affordable care act will have on
women's health and specifically for
pregnant women um so i'm five months
pregnant and we're actually qualified
have you considered
abortion
oh
geez
at the moment
senator cruz what policies do you have
in place to protect pregnant women from
losing their health coverage either due
to being considered having a
pre-existing condition or from being
charged higher insurance premiums than
men
well congratulations on your new babies
is it a boy or girl yes congratulations
right
congratulations and you said you have an
older child what's your older child we
have a two-year-old son what's his name
samson oh well
[Laughter]
every coverage on earth
and it sounds really good i you know i
had a conversation a couple of years ago
with a gentleman in amarillo texas who
told me the story about his 101 year old
aunt my personal story she's had her
insurance company
she said the reason it was canceled was
that it didn't cover maternity care
now this fellow laughed and said you
know what my aunt is 101 years old she
doesn't really need maternity say maria
i think that was them
we should have did we just hear
something going to the earpiece that we
weren't supposed to hear from cnn the
policies that meet somebody tweet us did
that actually happen did anyone else
just hear them
giving everyone a bus ticket when there
are no buses
what we should care about is access to
health care not just insurance oh there
we go i said that half an hour happened
under obamacare is that millions of
people can't afford it
we should be concerned about people
being able to afford health insurance
and that means giving them the choice in
50 states to choose a policy in your
instance you would choose a policy that
had maternity coverage but someone else
who right now kind of can't afford it
might choose a different policy and when
government mandates that those choices
go away senator sanders yourself
um people said yes they heard maria yes
what tit is really telling this is gonna
be a conspiracy announcement
they were saying something
and not every pregnancy is planned
and here we go woman under
a one pregnant woman before obama
because i don't know
wait for it a pre-existing condition
and now why would an insurance company
want to provide care to you when your
party considers it a parasite piece of
[ __ ]
doing that
and ted keeps talking about
these mandates so let's be clear again
what senator cruz and his republican
friends want to do
they do not want to guarantee
that women who become pregnant
will be able to get the health care and
the prenatal care that they need which
is a terrible thing by the way because
we have one of the highest infant
mortality rates
i mean murdering the best people who
today are on their parents program
you're out you're on your own after you
leave college
he says that if you come down with a
terrible illness and you're ending up
spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars your insurance company can now
tell you
that there is a limit to what they will
pay
and he is telling 20 million people who
gained health insurance under obamacare
sorry you're out on the streets
bottom line is once again
the discussion if you really
think about the kinds of discussion that
we're having it is an absurd discussion
for the wealthiest nation in the history
of the world senator sanders let me
follow up on that
i want to respond to that real briefly
please go ahead
you know it's interesting sometimes the
rhetoric that our friends on the left
like to say that anyone who doesn't
support government control of our health
care
somehow doesn't like and fit in whatever
population you're talking about
good cause let's again go back to facts
and let's talk about young people
you know there's no group in america i
think that's been hurt more by obamacare
than young people
young people were left on the chopping
block let's talk about some basic stats
a recent study found
that the obamacare mandates what bernie
just sang
an ode to
have increased the three costliest
mandates of increased premiums for
younger people by 44
without those mandates the typical 21
year old would pay
1100 a year less if you're 21
think about whether it would be easier
to afford health care if it costs eleven
hundred dollars a year or less he can't
appeal to the bernie voter base because
they think they should get free health
care until they're 26.
plan that was available
for a year old texan
for a 30 year old texan woman was 470 a
year
today under obamacare
the cheapest plan that's available for a
healthy 30 year old woman in fort worth
is
two hundred and thirty six dollars it's
gone from four hundred and seventy
dollars to three thousand over three
thousand two hundred much higher young
people
and what obamacare did
is it jacked up the rates on all the
young people why do you think there's an
individual
it's to force young people to pay really
high rates to subsidize the rest of the
system
and if you don't pay it the irs finds
you and you know over six million people
are fined each year by the irs under
obama senator we're going to get to
we're going to get to the question of
fines and so forth in a minute but i
want to circle back to women's health
and ask you senator sanders
why should a 60 year old male or women
who are beyond child bearing years
be required to have health insurance
plans that have maternity care
i don't think they should
but i do think that's what obamacare
does
but i do believe
that in the united states of america
where we talk a lot about our love for
children
that
pregnancy is not and should not be
considered a pre-existing condition
that every woman in this country who
gets pregnant should be 100 percent
assured that she is going to get the
highest quality care she needs to
deliver a healthy baby senator cruz i
want to stay on uh the issue of women's
health how under obama that feels good
that oh he's for me but he has no plan
to do it thank you so you contributed
nothing to this thing under any
republican replacement
it's going to be a choice for each
patient to make listen obamacare is all
about
are you on your first beer still jared
suck it man
number two
okay
i don't believe
every man
people will say gosh i'd like that
imagine if the federal government
mandated he's a bilingual drug everyone
in america must drive a lamborghini a
bad accident no i've never driven a
lamborghini i mean they look kind of fun
but you know what i'm willing to bet
most of us if that was the mandate and
it'd be cool you say leather seats you
could go i don't know 200 miles an hour
what it would mean for most people you
couldn't afford a car
if they said but you know gosh the bw is
not fancy enough you need everything for
most people who can't afford it it
doesn't work that's what obamacare is
doing i ride my bike for everyone it has
four gears you know but there's no magic
fairy with pixie dust
that gives it away
it's putting people in a situation like
laronda where they get nothing they
don't get health care of any kind
her employees don't get health care
because obamacare has driven the cost up
and that's why people are hurting so
much under two points our employees are
not getting health care because in texas
you did not expand medicaid under the
affordable care act
now she has 49 employees she's not
covered under and she's not hiring more
[Music]
[Laughter]
and also what we should be clear about
is ted says well it's just not enough
money we all can't drive fancy cars i
think it's a bit disingenuous to talk
about driving a fancy car with getting
access to health care when you're sick
last point on this issue
if we repeal the affordable care act we
are going to provide
346
billion dollars in tax breaks to the top
two percent what ted in other ways even
further
drink he wants what do you love
two tenths of one percent
the very wealthiest people in this
country and give them collectively
hundreds of billions of dollars in tax
breaks ted we are the wealthiest country
in the world
and it's not a question of everybody
driving a fancy car but it is a question
to making sure that every man woman and
child in this country has health care as
a right i want to bring it back i want
to bring it back to you
real quickly i know this gentleman has a
question
about the estate
what bernie said real quickly i want to
respond to you just briefly
uh which you know it was interesting in
the course of of the campaign last year
uh i would encounter young people all
over the country there were a lot of
young people who supported our campaign
a lot of young people who supported
bernie's and i would talk with different
people supporting bernie
and i'd say to them typically young
people i'd say you know what i agree
with bernie and they'd sort of look at
me they'd be startled they said what are
you talking about i said listen bernie
talks about how washington is corrupt
how both parties are corrupt how both
parties are in bed with big business and
big money and it is a corrupt system
benefiting the special interest i agree
absolutely and entirely
and what i tell folks is where i
disagree
if the problem is government is corrupt
why on earth would you want more power
in washington i want to take power out
of washington and empower the people
when it comes to taxes what i want to
see is a simple flat tax of 10 for
everyone and abolish the irs
that ends the power of the lobbyists it
ends the power of washington that's a
solution that empowers the people we're
going to we're going to
talk about
and in the midst of massive
unprecedented income and wealth
inequality ted's plan according to the
wall street journal would give
incredible tax breaks to the company
okay we'll do another we'll do another
we'll do another town hall debate on tax
reform okay we're gonna take a very
quick break and when we come back a
subject where there might be some
agreement the debate continues with
senators ted cruz and bernie sanders in
a moment what color is this the restroom
can you handle this one yeah sure gerald
and jared you got it awesome
i don't know what we do now i don't know
i'm fiddling with my balls like bernie
sanders
uh so do we just talk
about this is how we talk steven and
good talk about steven make fun of him a
little bit i think good i think we can
definitely do that bernie's bernie
just keeps coming back with like
he he opens his mouth because i think
there's a lag time between when the
thought happens in his head and when the
actual words come out i think he starts
talking
six seconds prior to when sound comes
out
and he leans forward yes he opens his
mouth his brain thinks that he's talking
but he's not actually making sound yet
he does seem slow tonight he just seemed
kind of like he seems like he seems a
little off his rocker well it's hard to
say if he's if he's is he just gathering
his thoughts is he trying to form a
sentence i don't think he's just not
remember where he's at i don't think
he's used to talking to somebody who has
data and facts i think he's used to
talking to a crowd of people that hear
free stuff
and that hear that that they can get
everything that they want without having
to face the realities of life and deal
with struggle by the way well i mean
sure he's i'm sure he's been on this the
senate floor and stuff but this is
probably the first time you think about
it you know through all the primaries
that's him and hillary they agreed on 90
of everything exactly yeah so he was
never
a force to to make his case to somebody
who had even a slightly different
opinion let alone a ted cruz who has
he's you know he's excellent on the
floor you've seen him with the uh the
sierra club you've seen him with the
other people he's you know he's he's a
master debater some may say yeah no and
this is what i liked about this i
understand that there's people out there
who don't like ted cruz um but here's
here's really what i want i want people
to take the content of the argument yeah
and and just base your opinion on that i
don't i don't care if you like or
dislike bernie i don't care if you like
or dislike
uh ted cruz or even cnn right so some
people oh cnn every one of these
questions is loaded right it's not
that's not the case it's not what
happens it it sometimes is like that but
sometimes they're getting out of the way
and just take it based on that news
comes when they report on all this
tomorrow exactly yeah that's the thing
said that uh he basically agrees with
bernie sanders yes
take it completely out of context inside
that's the clip they're going to play
every single time right now that's
that's the game that we put them in the
position of playing because
what's that
group yeah exactly
statistics to ted cruz talking about
feeling and you're like wait did you
actually watch the debates last night so
now we're still waiting for them no
everybody else is still on beverage one
or two i don't know but we've got we've
got ultrasound
talking right now all right sorry folks
how bad was it tweet me at s crowder it
wasn't bad hey i got a few people in my
favor someone check edward the sound
guy's wine bottle we will we will
definitely check it because it's dark
you can't oh he's he's about a glass and
a half in i'm an expert on these things
i've got a couple of people saying they
want to see me more often i mean there's
two out of 17 million people gazillion
people there's two two yeah family
doesn't count right
but hillary did say something very
important and i mean the good hillary
stevens hillary she said we need to show
us a shot of hopper
she wants to see a little bit more
hopper action oh there he is look at him
he is tearing up the duck
well you wrote bernie it's almost kind
of like kind of like what ted cruz is
doing to bernie sanders it really is in
a loving way it looks very affectionate
like a very affectionate feeling right
there i'm beating the crap get that out
you get that out of the screenshot jared
i'm going to get that screenshot of the
screenshot screenshot
which screenshot has got who's using my
iphone says jennifer is using my iphone
well that's fun my iphone's in the green
room
all right we're back yeah boy
welcome back to the cnn debate on the
future of obamacare let's turn now to
the rise in prescription drugs
he comes from denver colorado he's a
father of two whose daughter juniper
requires medication that would cost 900
a month without medicaid he came down
for this town hall from an evening of
moonshining
of my daughter's life-saving
prescriptions
this luckily hasn't been an unbearable
financial burden for my family because
of obamacare and particularly the
medicaid expansion
senator cruz regardless
additionally how would you like to
address a health care system where
insurance companies can choose to not
cover drugs that people like my daughter
need to live
well thank you for the question and
thank you for the care you give that
your three-year-old daughter i know that
that that is not easy and and the
question you ask is one of the great
challenges facing this country is we've
seen the cost of drugs increasing
dramatically one area bernie and i
talked about we agree on is allowing the
importation of drugs into this country
from other countries where they're
cheaper there's no reason why we should
be subsidizing other countries across
the globe but another fundamental area
is fda reform where the cost of getting
a new drug approved are prohibitedly
expensive i i don't know if you've ever
seen or folks have ever seen the movie
dallas buyers club
it's a wonderful movie with matthew
mcconaughey about a gentleman a
gentleman in town that's a good point
that's the one with jared leto get drugs
to care for it
trying to get life-saving drugs
there is story after story after story
of exactly that happening life-saving
drugs that are available that are
approved they're used in europe cruises
actually seem to house buyers
they show that at the church meeting
valuable that if we lift the barriers to
let people try give you a right to try
give if it's your life you have a right
to choose you have to use shows
listen the big boys the big players
government regulation dodd-frank
benefited the big banks
tough fda barriers to entry benefit the
big pharmaceutical companies massive
complexity and tax laws benefits big
corporations
by reducing those barriers we have
competition and there's the opportunity
i believe we have can have innovative
cures to give you a sense
the four most devastating diseases in
terms of human life and dollars
heart disease also derrick newton says
we missed a well let's honor it
we ought to be investing everything we
can to cure those diseases just curing
cancer an incredible achievement
would save
50 trillion dollars
and countless lives across the globe
thank you so much the fda is a barrier
to dr berzenski in houston
just as the case with health care
netflix we pay amazon prime one of the
two the highest prices in the world for
prescription drugs 15 years ago you know
what i did i took a bus load of women
working-class women from vermont
dealing with breast cancer across the
canadian border
and they had the smear
it's going to get funny real quick
of the price they're paying they were
paying in the united states of america
tears were coming out of these
working-class women's eyes fighting for
their lives what's going on what's going
on is the pharmaceutical industry owns
the united states congress and in all
senses
i will admit it's not just republicans
they have a huge influence on huge
parties
so right now the reality is uniquely in
the whole world you can walk in tomorrow
to the so this is a two or four
we have to tell the pharmaceutical
industry which in 2015
made 50 billion dollars in profit for
the five major companies
where the top 10 competitors made over
300 million dollars
in profit how much they invest however
do they have hired how much risk did
they take the risk have taken two things
that we can do immediately ted is right
i introduced and will introduce
credit for introducing the legislation
ted is right he signed on to my bill
pharmacists and distributors and the
american people he's like the matchmaker
for shitty legislation
but
we should be negotiating
drug prices through medicare medicaid oh
there it is
for medicine right now republicans put
language in some years ago
which prevents them from negotiating
prices i would hope ted will join me
in saying that
medicare should be able to do what the
va does we can lower prices oh good
let's use the va is a shiny example of
how the system got 1400 well-paid
lobbyists right now and they're working
they're working against you they're
working against your daughter the only
thing they want is more and more profit
oh they could care less like a parody of
the american people well but bernie the
barriers are also coming from government
and and i'll give an example a texas
constituent cassie lay has a
seven-year-old daughter cassie
when she was seven months old
and there's there's a drug called
that is used all across the world to
treat the conditions she has she has the
most
gastroparesis
she was put on don pereira this the
seven month old girl she was off the
feeding tube she was living well
don peredone is available in more than a
hundred countries including canada and
throughout the years
and i'll tell you what cassie's mother
said
i fear she will need to get a feeding
tube again
how do i tell her that she's a little
girl who has worked extremely hard to
overcome her fears of eating and now her
joy of just being a
normal little girl will be taken away we
shouldn't have the government putting
barriers to people getting the drugs
they i think that that's the thing
you should see the sound guy i can't
drink anymore
mine's 13 percent damn
in this area i think it might be a lot
easier if we only need to drive home in
vermont
[Laughter]
will you join me i do appreciate you
coming on board the reimportation i
really do and we can win it if we get
republican support
will you stand with me
you're saying that medicare which spends
a huge amount of medicare for
prescription drugs should be able to
negotiate prices oh listen of course
medicare should negotiate but you and i
have a different view on how you control
greed
hold on hold on let me finish what i'm
saying your view you said before that
gosh these executives make way too much
money i don't think the government
should be in the business of deciding
what you get paid and you get paid and
you get paid
and there are socialist countries on
earth there are socialist countries that
you encourage us to be like
but those countries
are not doing nearly as well as america
you know the per capita income in
america is over five times the average
per capita income in this world it's 50
more than the per capita income in
europe this is a land of opportunity
because there's social mobility in
socialist countries
a dishwasher like my dad did and the
free enterprise system in this country
lets people rise so i don't think the
answer is at this point just to be there
at the end of it it's going to be like
robert de niro raging bull you never got
me down
you didn't get me down cruz
you never got me down
ceos have seen compensation packages
yeah that does concern me terms of
socialist countries do you think denmark
and sweden
uh and finland
are terrible in sweden
he's also racist those are all white
countries
to the to america and to the affordable
care act
throughout your campaign you said the
taxes should go up on the rich not the
middle class and yet millions of
americans vilified the middle class
not to get health care are forced to pay
a tax penalty so families of four are
paying up to two thousand dollars per
year for failing to purchase coverage
many say that they can't afford the
premium so it's just cheaper for them to
pay the penalty
than get health care so is it fair to
put this tax burden on families no it's
not but on the other hand is it fair
to not raise the revenue that we need to
provide
oh but we need it it's for a good cause
no it's not let's fix this yeah no it's
not i guess but we need to do it anyways
because i'm a prickly
two millionaires and billionaires
not a millionaire billionaire you just
took a steaming dump on her bernie
i just squeezed out
a corn infested
piping rod
anytime a liberal goes after a small
business owner they just burn it on her
okay that's gotta be a new thing hashtag
bernie i just took a worm
pungent but if you repeal it peanut
filled with peanuts
well dana let me point out that that
bernie acknowledged that six and a half
million americans are paying obamacare
tax fines because they can't afford
insurance so they can't afford health
insurance and then the irs comes in and
finds them and he says gosh i don't
agree with that and yet throughout the
democratic debate bernie says he helped
write obamacare that imposes these fines
on people i think it's wrong to be
finding people but let me make a broader
point on time
many times
he did he just did this we've talked
about providing health care for free
from the government you know what
the simplest principle in economics is
tonstaffle there ain't no such thing as
a free lunch
the liberal-leaning urban institute
scored bernie's health plan concluded it
would cost 2.5 trillion dollars in the
first year and 32 trillion dollars over
10 years now how much is that trillions
is a big number it's not clear what that
is let me put it in perspective
all of the federal income taxes we pay
today are about 1.5 trillion a year i
feel like any minute bernie will just
say
[ __ ] it who wants to go to norms
[Laughter]
to get an additional 2.5 trillion now
bernie no doubt is going to come back
and say no no no none of you are going
to pay
just the rich
well how about if we took every person
that makes over a million dollars a year
here you go and confiscated a hundred
percent of their income every
he's smiling look at him that would
raise only enough money to fund bernie's
plan for five months you just orgasm
oh i thought this was gonna work good
of apple
google microsoft facebook and exxon
mobil if it came in illegally sold seize
those companies and sold them
that would pay for one year of bernie's
plan that's right if you don't want to
see your taxes triple
in addition to the wait list in addition
to the rationing in addition to fewer
mris and mammograms he will not address
this in his response he absolutely will
not address but it's absolutely
impossible to pay for
i'm gonna say absolutely ted cruz just
took a bernie on bernie
sanders journal he did that bernie the
bernie you killed me
2015.
ted cruz's wall street journal
[Laughter]
adding about one-third to their
after-tax income here is the economic
reality facing america he's not
addressing in the last 35 years
there has been a massive transfer of
wealth from the middle class and the
working class to the top one tenth of
one percent we're talking about
trillions of dollars
ted's response to that is he's gonna
support the repeal of the estate tax
correct you're on record
and bernie's now going to say he wants
to favor the rich address those numbers
bernie in a college debate club right
now you'd be called on it
so this right-wing hyperbola about we
can confiscate everybody it's not going
to do anything here is the big it's true
if we pass the sanders plan
95
of people in this country
would have more after-tax income than
they have right now
senators i'm sorry it's clear we have
a lot more to debate and we can do that
at a later time
he didn't address it at all he was asked
a very serious question he was he was
given numbers and statistics to deal
with and he took a bernie uh you know we
should check in here we're getting late
in the evening is is jongi do we have
zhang jiang
zhang lee are you still there mr journey
for bernie are you there
john gee
oh my gosh
yeah
yeah man hey hey
hi man
hey can you can you hear me still i can
i can yeah i can hear you hear that
scarless what your mother
is a box turtle oh a box turtle box
turtles yeah you know don't don't cut to
me anymore okay i'm going to i don't i'm
going to enjoy my beer and [ __ ] peace
okay that's it
[Laughter]
a box turtle i just that's that's an
insult okay tweet me at s crowder or at
not jared or at g morgan jr
i try to look at things objectively you
know when i looked at the debates
remember we said trump won one hillary
won uh one of them clearly i'm trying to
remember the order and then one of them
was a bit of a toss-up you might give to
hillary
in this context
i think it's pretty clear-cut ted cruz
has severely dominated bernie sanders i
think he run ruled him for all you you
know minor league baseball or i'm sorry
a little league baseball fans like this
is when you call the game after the
third inning because it's making the
other team not want to compete and play
the sport or mercy exactly the mercy
rule is in full effect here ted just
mopped the floor with him but i will say
this he was in danger of doing too good
of a job and he he was able to soften it
up pretty well he made some really good
connections some jokes
said that he liked bernie and he agreed
with him on look it looks tough if you
keep going to the exact body on a 98
yeah you start to be
you got to go to the body on tonight 98
year old i'm surprised he's still
standing uh by the way there are a lot
of pictures of bernie fiddling with his
balls tonight and in case you haven't
seen those him walking around with his
hands
cupping his
genitals
cupping his scrotum and testicles you
know they would fit perfectly in a
louder with crowder mug
as not gage aaron knows all too well yes
indeed
put them in your single origin coffee
jared i believe they call that tea bag i
don't know what i'm just saying
well it's not really tea bagging at that
point
okay so closing statements what do we
expect to see in closing statements i
expect ted cruz to
close the statement that he agrees with
bernie on the idea that healthcare needs
to be fixed but that if you look at the
facts and statistics or to some degree
thereof you will see that government has
not solved the problem and has made it
worse particularly under obama i expect
bernie sanders to say uh we need more
equality and the rich are not paying
their fair share and it's time to get
along with all the other countries in
the world and make their health care
plan plans are those his notes by the
way or is that the denny's takeout menu
i've always curious
no no for
the one white piece of paper he's had
they'll only notice that all night i
want corned beef no pastrami no pressure
no coffee
yeah what do you do gerald i think it's
yeah it's that's definitely what's going
to happen um he doesn't have
any kind of argument and so he's just
going to connect emotionally ted cruz if
he's smart he's going to keep facts in
there but he's also going to connect a
little bit emotionally at the end and
make sure he makes the point we want
health care insurance
like he's too smart for you but
sometimes he comes off really well and i
think he's done that tonight so i think
he's done a great job and i think he'll
if he connects we'll be fine okay that's
a good point well you're saying what
they need i said what i think they will
do
and that's good insight from gerald uh
morgan uh what they need to do uh of
course as usual no insight from not gay
jared we are back
other than he's not gay not
statements gay senator will get two
minutes we're going to begin with
senator bernie sanders senator
well let me thank ted for being here let
me thank cnn for sponsoring
this debate which i thought has been a
very interesting
discussion um
as i see it there was discussion
political problems with the voices right
now in my head is that we have a
congress that is more interested in
representing their campaign contributors
and the very wealthy than the needs of
ordinary americans ted ran a very
vigorous campaign for president
congratulate them
but ted also received 36 million dollars
in that campaign from three billionaires
three
billionaires and as a result of citizens
united we're now looking at the koch
brothers the second wealthiest family in
america
and other billionaires
literally buying elections
and that translates into
so they're not buying elections very
well
and the pharmaceutical industry and the
medical equipment suppliers than they do
about about the needs of the american
people who provides it
dumb ass very fine questions that people
here ask tonight and you take a step
backward you say whoa
what kind of craziness is this
we are the wealthiest country in the
history of the world
and yet we have tens and tens and tens
of millions of people struggling with
prescription drugs struggling with basic
health care yes we can do better than
that
and then on top of all of that we end up
spending almost twice as much per capita
on health care as do the people of any
other country
now
protect the rest of the world nor create
the drugs that all the other countries
enjoy bernie
we have got to go further but what ted
wants to do is do away with many of the
patient protection
bills provisions that were passed
pre-existing conditions
what's
making sure that women are not
discriminated against making sure that
young people can stay on their parents
insurance programs on the ted's idea all
of that is gone you are on your own i
think that is a very bad idea thank you
senator senator no that was nothing i
want to thank bernie for being here and
for being a vigorous and honest debater
he believes what he believes and he
represents it well and i want to thank
each of you for spending so much time
addressing this this critically
important issue
you know i'd like to take a minute and
actually ask the people here if the
cameras could turn for a moment to to
the folks in the audience i want to ask
you
how many of you here
in the last six years
have seen your health insurance premiums
or your deductibles go up
yep
right here you ask another question in
the studio how many of you here know
somebody
including yourself
who's had your insurance policy canceled
in the last six years oh that's me too
yeah really yeah if you look at these
hands across the room this is why people
are so unhappy with obamacare
then they realize it isn't working
because it was built on an edifice of
lies
when politicians promised the american
people if you like your plan you can
keep your plan if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor and six million
people get their plans
cancelled
against their wishes those are broken
promises
when the president of the united states
promises your premiums will drop twenty
five hundred dollars and instead the
average premium rises five thousand
dollars in deductibles go up five
thousand dollars people are hurting
because of obamacare and bernie's
solution you know almost nobody even on
the left questions the facts that ted
cruz brings to the table
their criticism is he's too mechanical
not that he's wrong and every time they
recorded his solution is more cowbell
more cowbell
more counting government control that
messed this all up
and bernie in the democrats solution is
more cowbell more cowbell
yeah it didn't work when we said you
wouldn't get your plan canceled yeah it
didn't work when we said your premiums
would be cut but give government even
more power
we can do better i believe
we're going to honor the promises we
made to the american people
and we're going to repeal what bill
clinton called obamacare the craziest
law in the world instead we're going to
give you choice
let you buy insurance across state loans
expand health savings account make
insurance
portable
block grant medicaid to the state so you
can have experimentation health savings
accounts so we can meet your needs put
you in charge of your health care with
your doctor that's not your middle name
that's what this election was about and
now it is incumbent on all of us
republicans and democrats to deliver
on the promises made to the american
people our thanks to senators cruz and
senator sanders for joining us here
tonight
and we also want to thank our audience
here our host and
we want to thank our audience who we uh
pulled from the intensive care ward
at the cleveland clinic okay so let's
wrap this up you know what's funny is we
pretty much predicted the final
statements to a t we did yes between us
were brilliant this is why they make ted
cruz out to be evil because ted cruz is
better than his opposition ted cruz is
smarter he's able to provide this
information
it's very rare that you hear people if
they fact check ted cruz on one thing
it's national news because it's pretty
rare if they fact ted they'll probably
say
ted cruz will probably become a meme
where he said congratulations on your
struggle with whatever it was so that's
what they'll pick out and that's why
people don't trust the media anymore
it's not that the media isn't
necessarily right in questioning things
it's that they decide to make an entire
issue out of kellyanne conway's poor
stand-up just like they'll make an
entire issue out of ted cruz's
congratulations on your struggle with
it's pretty clear what he meant to say
congratulations on your overcoming on
your success on your recidivism whatever
it is um
honestly the drinking game sounds
trivial it sounds silly but it was
remarkably predictable
and that's why we do this by design
because
it is so easy to see where the left is
going to come from unless now
if you're going to debate a leftist you
have to assume that they know everything
you have to assume that they know what
they're talking about but
ted cruz here came prepared and bernie
sanders didn't bernie said this this is
the example of where we talk about
mainstream leftism they're so much in a
bubble they are so much in an echo
chamber the [ __ ] hat economics and the
women's march and the black lives matter
and the banning people on college campus
if you look at it they create an
environment where they can only hear
from like-minded people
they're not used to getting any other
team shuttle they're not used to
actually getting out on the field
and playing a single down and we saw
that tonight bernie never got to make it
to a primary
and uh
we saw what happens you know when it's
the difference between kung fu fake
martial arts and really getting to the
mat really getting in the cage and i
think that's what we saw with bernie
sanders i don't think it was equipped no
no he wasn't at all and it's funny that
you say that they they want to surround
themselves with the same ideas and they
actually react violently to people who
oppose those ideas there's a religion
that kind of does that too and i can't
remember if it's uh oh oh islam yes
that's right
i was going to say mormons well
that's true special underwear and
everything but these guys don't want to
hear truth but yet they are the people
that are teaching
across this country on college campuses
the next generation
so you gotta you gotta win the hearts
and minds of the people that are about
to leave college and they cannot
cannot cannot be bernie supporters
that's changing though
because because the bernie supporters on
campus and the rest have reached so far
yeah that the just anyone with any
common sense left is going all right
they're calling everyone nazis they're
burning stuff down they're punching
people in berkeley
this is not what i'm about and i think i
think bernie will be less and less
relevant because of the extremism that
is now mainstream leftism yeah they're
actually protesting free speech by
banning free speech so i i don't
understand how this goes but i think if
the economy does well under trump you're
going to see a lot fewer protests you're
going to see a lot fewer socialists come
about i mean can you imagine
50 years ago somebody like bernie
sanders out there parading around and
saying socialism is not a bad word we
need to get comfortable with socialism
and what that means and understand it
can you imagine that that's even a
possibility after what we saw socialism
in the world
70 something years ago it's called
stalin yeah exactly we've been down this
road before do people not read history
books not good jared you're read
you're just doing that
with all of the above all right so there
we go i think it was an overall
successful live stream evening not gay
jade will be driven home by g morgan so
at g morgan jr at not gay jared me at s
credit let us know what you think
tomorrow we'll be uploading some clips i
think it was a success i think ted cruz
uh did well i think bernie sanders came
ill-equipped you saw this was exactly
what we always predicted we said i want
to see bernie versus ted socialism
versus conservatism it was the appeal to
emotion
versus
facts statistics logic um
also
no boogers were eaten so i would
consider tonight a success
go home drive safely enjoy your smear of
pap we'll see you tomorrow with cassie j
[Music]
it only takes a time
[Music]